In this problem, a building is undergoing construction.
A 20-foot beam used to hold 40 kips in its center.
The point load is being removed and the engineer wants to determine the equivalent distributed
force per linear foot that can be applied to the beam instead.
The equivalent force in kips per foot is most nearly 1, 2, 3 or 4.
So in this problem, we have a beam that used to receive a point force that we want to convert
into an equivalent distributed load.
So what we can do is first go to chapter 4 of our civil reference handbook, which will
be pages 236 or 238, or if you're going by the PDF page numbers, it's 248 and 250.
So the list of beams provided there gives you the sheer diagrams for each of those types
of beams as well as the equations.
So if we were to go to number 7 first, 7 is our simple beam with a point load at center.
Alright, so that case looks like the first one over here and we can see that the equation
provided for sheer in this case, it's using r is equal to v, which is sheer, which is equal
to the point load over 2.
So in this case, sheer is going to be equal to the load of 40 kips over 2, so 20 kips.
Now if we were to look at the other diagram of what the distributed load looks like for
the sheer, that's going to be the first one listed on page 236 or 248, depending
on if you're going by the book pages or the PDF pages.
And that is given as a simple beam with a uniformly distributed load.
So the max sheer in this case is going to be w, which is the distributed load, l, which
is the length of the beam over 2 minus x.
So if we look at the sheer diagram for this beam, we can see that the max sheer is going
to occur at the edges.
So in this case, x is going to be equal to 0, max sheer.
So in this case, it's just w, l over 2.
And we've already been given the max sheer that we need to account for from the previous
beam type.
So what we're going to do now is just plug in our equation and finish the problem.
So 20 kips equals w, which is what we're solving for.
l is 20 feet and just over 2.
So in this case, w equals 2 kips per foot.
And that's all it takes to solve this problem.